what is going on everybody welcome to
the third a debugging Python tutorial in
this tutorial the next couple tutorials
we're going to be talking about
arithmatic errors or arithmetic errors
this is going to be pretty useful a lot
of people use Python for large
mathematical calculations because it
doesn't have the limit of 2.1 for 7
billion that a lot of programming
languages do so a lot of people do use
it and if you use in do interestingly
enough mathematical calculations then
you're going to run into a few different
types of errors or automatically or even
you might run into some memory errors
when you exceed your memory limits which
also runs into something else but we'll
talk about that when we get there that's
not a rhythmic error so we're not in
terment so first arrow that we're gonna
talk about is gonna be the overflow air
and this air is almost I think it's
always gonna be in relation to when the
actual like result of your mathematical
equation the result itself is just too
big so the amount of digits in your in
your result it's just way too big to be
represented so or the digit length I
suppose is the better way to put it so
the only time that you'll have this
occur is going to be when you have a
decimal point that's doing it so the
easiest way for me to do this is to show
you guys a quick example and yep so
we're gonna do import math and then
we'll do exponent and we'll do negative
one times and then we'll come down times
and then we'll do negative zero point
like that pool so we'll save that we'll
run it and sure enough what prints out
is an overflow error it's a math range
error and it just means that your result
has way too many digits basically now
again this isn't for like a really
really large like long integer it's
gonna happen most often when you have
just a huge desk like an ongoing decimal
again I don't know if you try to
calculate pi maybe or something just um
way too many decimals and and actually I
bet if you calculated PI you'd hit a
memory error probably first but anyway
generally if you see this error you've
probably you know created your equation
wrong if anything
so probably the way to solve this error
is to go back to your equation and see
where you went wrong to give you that
many decimal points so that's overflow
error as always thanks for watching